to pakistan now where parliament is
meeting in the coming hours to choose
the new prime minister who will replace
imran khan who was ousted over the
weekend
securities high after tens of thousands
of people across the country answered
khan's call to protest against his
removal from office
he's thanked his supporters for opposing
what he calls
a u.s backed regime
this is the change time in pakistan that
people are worried after the ousting of
a government people are concerned about
why their leader has been ousted why he
has been pushed behind
the last decision will be of the people
in a democratic system the final voice
will be the voice of the people and the
voice of the people is imran khan
let's get a reminder of how we reach
this point the original no confidence
motion against then prime minister imran
khan was brought to parliament by the
opposition back on march 28th a week
later parliament's deputy speaker who is
an ally of khan blocked the motion
claiming it was influenced by foreign
news
and the president on imran khan's
recommendation dissolved the assembly
setting the stage for elections
but last thursday pakistan's highest
court ruled that the disillusion was
unconstitutional and khan then lost a
no-confidence vote on saturday
osama bin javed is live for us in
islamabad talk us through what happens
today osama
well in the next few hours pakistan is
all set to elect its 23rd prime minister
after imran khan was voted out the first
prime minister to have been voted out of
the assembly uh all eyes are on the
national assembly where two candidates
are going to vie for this top job uh
former foreign minister sharma mud
qureshi from imran khan's party and
shabbat sharif a candidate of the joint
opposition who is most likely to win the
votes because they had the numbers to
oust imran khan and to discuss that
discuss this we have with us the former
governor of since province mr muhammad
zubair thank you very much for being
with us imran khan was able to bring out
thousands of people across pakistan
it's a narrative that an alignment of
corrupt politicians the judiciary the
military is all out to get him and he's
going to come back to power how do you
come to that i think this the most
important point is
missing in this link
there's no one else responsible for the
downfall of imran khan but imran khan
himself he brought it on himself
i mean
you know if he had built up a strong
cabinet which was which included
competent people
responsible to deliver
on the economic front that's the key
most important objective and he totally
missed that and this in spite of the
fact that he was the first prime
minister who got the kind of support
from all stakeholders including the
military
unprecedented support the judiciary the
media he was the darling of the media
when he came in power so all the major
stakeholders were all behind him and
everyone also felt uh and to
to some sense that
i think
give
civilian leadership the opportunity uh
to perform rather than being disturbed
unnecessarily
and he got that sport and he failed
miserably so he brought it on himself
now how confident are you that shabbat
sharif is going to win the vote he also
has pending allegations of corruption
money laundering against him so what
does that say about is he's he the best
candidate out of all the opposition
leaders combined by far the best
candidate i mean first he has the kind
of experience the inside the political
wisdom
he has performed at a very big stage as
the chief minister of the largest
province of pakistan for 10 10 long
years and no one including
the
opponents imran khan's party supporters
would doubt his ability to deliver he
has done it so we have done it at the
federal level we have done it at the
punjab government level
his team obviously will include many of
the stalwarts who were part of the team
in 2013 to 2018 they have the experience
the quality and everything so i think
he's by far the best candidate by far
the the point about his the allegations
obviously that's her point that the
government's job is to focus on its
prime responsibility of governance
economic delivery foreign policy and
others as far as accountability is
concerned whichever
authority wants to conduct any
legitimate investigation i mean
shivashreef has been going through that
for the last four years very quickly now
pakistan is in a precarious situation
when it comes to economy when it comes
to the status of political disarray
30 seconds what are you going to do and
how can you take pakistan out of it i
mean the good news is first the creating
confidence among the investors and
potential investors and the main
stakeholders already this morning the
stock is up 14 40 points which is
unprecedented the dollar has come down
since that decision of last thursday of
the supreme court from 190 to around 192
that's the kind of confidence that pmln
always creates whenever it comes in
power so that is the starting point then
obviously as you take key economic
decisions on how to go about and we have
a very good plan that the team has
prepared so hopefully mrs aware thank
you very much for being with us that's
the former governor of sindh province
muhammad zubair speaking to us he's
about to go into the parliament as
voting is all set to begin
the focus now seems to be from the
politicians to go towards delivery and
move away from the politics of
allegations which they accuse imran khan
of orchestrating in the last three and a
half years it's going to be an
interesting day to watch thank you for
that osama bin java there for us in
islamabad